[Music]
hi guys it's quinn here if you enjoy my
videos consider hitting the like button
it's the only way the youtube algorithm
really notices me
today we will be discussing the blind
site by peter watts
now we as humans tend to view
evolution in a very
self-centralizing way we tend to imagine
that the most intelligent species will
be the most dominant species
we tend to imagine that a species
evolving equals a species becoming
smarter
but scientifically that's obviously not
the case the most successful species on
this planet are not intelligent in the
slightest we are so used to seeing
depictions of alien civilizations that
are different from us but still in some
way fundamentally like us
operating based on at least some form of
reason operating based on some form of
comprehension we assume that in order
for a species to travel the stars
intelligence is necessary so therefore
we assume that most if not all
space-faring civilizations
would be
to some degree
intelligent but if we truly think about
this reasonably
wouldn't exactly the opposite be true
the human brain is a tremendous resource
cost for our body other animals don't
have to worry about growing a huge brain
so they can put resources in other
places like reproduction which is
technically the goal of life when we
talk about what makes a species
successful the answer is not
intelligence plenty of intelligent
animals have gone extinct a good
measurement of the success of a species
is the population and the quality of
life and we all know that humanity has a
unique propensity for suffering that is
thanks to intelligence
so the blind site spoilers ahead by the
way
provides an interesting and rather
devastating idea
what if humanity
is just a fluke
now i should say that intelligence is
not precisely
the issue here the issue is self
awareness specifically
a creature could potentially be highly
intelligent while completely and utterly
lacking consciousness
completely and utterly lacking
self-awareness
so in essence
a step is cut out consciousness
gets in the way consciousness slows the
process
i waste energy and processing power
self obsesses to the point of psychosis
scramblers have no need of it
scramblers are more parsimonious
with simpler biochemistries
with smaller brains deprived of tools of
their ship even parts of their own
metabolism they think rings around you
they hide their language in plain sight
even when you know what they're saying
they turn your own cognition against
itself they travel between the stars
this is what intelligence can do on
hampered by self-awareness
so the scramblers who we encounter in
the blind site are the first
extraterrestrials that humankind has
ever come into contact with and they're
not conscious at all
but they have
several orders of magnitude more brain
power than human beings
but they use that brain power to operate
their exceptionally complex sensory
organs and musculature system
they're extremely fast extremely
reactive and formidable so
an interesting concept that this book
introduced me to is the concept of the
chinese room
now this book itself recognizes that the
actual idea of a chinese room is
actually a fallacy but for the purposes
of understanding this section of the
story the concept is adequate
imagine a man in a room and through a
hole in a wall he is being given pieces
of paper with symbols on them and he
also has access to a database of symbols
just like the ones that come through the
wall and rules that tell him how to put
those symbols together but the point is
he still doesn't have any idea what all
these symbols are or what information
they contain he only knows that when he
encounters a certain symbol he is to
respond with this set of rules involving
this set of symbols
now if you've ever heard of the turing
test this idea was originally thought to
be
the counter to the turing test now this
story brings up this idea in an
extremely creepy context for a while the
crew of the spaceship theses are
attempting to communicate with the alien
vessel they refer to it as rorschach and
the alien vessel is responding to them
in a human voice
so eventually they realize that the
voice that they're talking to
actually is a chinese room but what's
really creepy about it is how closely
this chinese room
resembles
actual comprehension
actual understanding
oh right rorschach said suddenly
we get it now
you don't think there's anyone here do
you
you've got some high-priced consultant
telling you there's nothing to worry
about jack was deep in the forest we'd
lost most of the tactical overlays to
reduce to bod in the dim visible light
rorschach's crate rigid spines each the
size of a skyscraper hashed a nightmare
view on all sides the feed stuttered as
baits struggled to keep the beam aligned
consensus painted walls and airspace
with arcane telemetry i had no idea what
any of it meant
you think we're nothing but a chinese
room rorschach sneered jack stumbled
towards collision grasping for something
to hang on to
your mistake theseus
the ship rorschach itself is also
terrifying it's described as like a
giant crown of thorns twisted and dark
and unreflective and just like way too
tangled to ever actually go on
somebody's head and also absolutely
giant with spikes the size of
skyscrapers so the combination of the
image of that vessel and the creepy
unnerving voice that's being transmitted
from it makes for really great horror in
my opinion
and this book has other really awesome
elements of horror for instance in this
book vampires actually existed at some
point during human history they were an
offshoot of humans that became predatory
towards other humans but they also had
this ability to go into hibernation for
long periods of time so actually in this
series they're able to through
biological engineering bring back
vampires and actually create hybrid
humans that actually have some of the
hibernation abilities of those vampires
one of the crew members of the ship
theseus saresti is actually a vampire
and he makes the other crew members very
nervous because at any time he could
revert back to his primal instincts and
decide to prey upon them so not only is
there this ominous extraterrestrial
threat from the outside there's also a
potential threat on the inside this book
also goes into other concepts like
self-hood and the idea of consciousness
being uploaded into a cloud it has many
of the great elements that i really just
love in science fiction so i definitely
would recommend this book to you guys if
you enjoy these elements and stories as
well there's also the sequel echopraxia
which i plan on covering at some point
in the future as well thank you guys so
much for watching make sure you like and
subscribe for more quinn's ideas
just a heads up for those of you that
may be interested my next graphic novel
the lie behind the star is launching
february 2023 you can sign up now to get
on the email mailing list to get
notified as soon as it launches more
information on my website link in the
description thank you guys so much
[Music]
you